it's a reality is that is that if you
want to have a great job you've got to
be able to think mathematically you have
to be through all of the math teachers
out there yeah and enter the students in
maths classrooms doing the maths maybe
who you haven't tasted what you're
talking about yeah for which it's almost
the kind of some areas is another
language what would you say to them to
teachers and to those students in you
know for for 10 11 years students have
to do maths yeah country yeah and so
they're there and they're doing it so
what would you say those two groups of
people we have to do Matt they do you
have to do it that's right I it's gonna
get out there and make mistakes make
things interesting for yourself discover
I think part of the thing with maths as
well is the fact that we get told so
much but it's better to kind of try just
try things out and be willing to fail
and also I I think it's I think it's I
have no I have no qualms whatsoever to
try something and fail in front of a
class and that's something very hard
because as a teacher you will get
questions like that you know that I
thought you're good you know and people
okay the teacher yeah exactly but but I
think it's fine to fail as because
that's everyone does it's hard stuff
that's is really hard it's something
that there's a super recent I we have a
vole our brains are so amazing and we've
evolved these senses you know and it's
like like for example if we read English
and we speak English and and you and
you'll see a word you cannot not see
that word
like it's impossible it's imprinted into
your mom it's internship and that's our
brains we are patterned seekers and the
patterns we seek it's there so strong
it's because our brain is geared towards
it and in mathematics we are looking for
these patterns that are abstract so
there there is this there is this kind
of this great pleasure you can get out
of it just like when you see something
there were those magic eyes you remember
those ones where are you going to sort
of not focus yeah and they're not focus
in three deep it comes up yeah or even
like an inkblot thing or whatever on but
yeah there's these um there are these
great patterns that you can discover and
it is really enjoyable to kind of get it
but you kind of have to really you know
it's sort of like learning learning
formulas memorizing formulas I mean I
can know I know why that's so hard the
idea that the the easiest way is just
memorization is is a fallacy it's the
easiest ways is understanding
understanding it is the is is being lazy
why understanding something yeah that's
your quickest path really yeah yeah and
that's right it is and also you're
equipped so for example like all those
tricks on you you know there's trig
functions like to sign collars equals
sine 2 theta all the expansions that all
those benches yes so I just I just
learned that was like e to the I theta
equals some cause i sine theta and and
that's all I needed to know because like
in an exam I would just I would just
write it out so I basically expand the
brackets and you can get everything else
ready and you got everything I needed
out of it but it was just the idea and
it's like I just knew it because it's
like even if I couldn't remember if it
was causal sign I could draw the circle
and I knew where that was and I knew
this on you and so it was like for me
it's like I had babushka dolls of like
how things would go and I don't think
put things together and I just thought
everyone did that but it's not true like
I've seen kids try and solve problems
who like got everything going for them
it's like you know they're willing to do
it and but it's there's this thing of
like just tell me how to do it
just tell that's all I want just just
tell me what to do and I'm gonna learn
that and it's right it's not how it
works guys you don't and you know what
that's any other party of life you
really wouldn't want there to be the
case that's right you know we we need to
have that sense of freedom and this is
intellectual freedom we're talking about
like understand it just understand it
and the benefits for her I mean like
that poorly understood but the benefits
are you you you will know how to think
and I think there is no one in Australia
who is going to stand up and say I'm
illiterate and I'm proud of it but you
have people go I am in numerous don't
talk to be about maths I've always been
bad peanuts yeah it's sure because who's
going to stand up and say I can't read
or write I mean people have great it's a
great deal of shame involved in that if
people were in that situation but we're
just happy to be in humor as we think of
without computers so what so what we got
computers you know I you know this is
actually this actually happened and
sorry I didn't give you a very concise
alright but no I this actually happened
in when I was my was first starting at
Fosters we had this thing where there's
a single price elasticity descansen here
baby yeah so price elasticity is you
take a certain product the the price
it's sold out effects its volume they
called price sensitive so think like
toilet paper price-sensitive you charge
more for it yeah and peeping and people
with you yeah all right and but then if
you're talking about you know an iphone
you can charge whatever you want they
were going to buy it and so you know I
mean it's like this is like it's that
idea of branding so if the brand itself
is so valuable people are willing to pay
whatever the price so the curve looks
like this right so pricey i assessed so
if something is called elastic which
means it moves with the price it has
this curve that looks like a slippery
dip and so anyway so when I was when I
started working at Fosters wine estates
it was like they wanted to bring this in
and they had the mat sky and it's a
we're going to spend 250 thousand
dollars on a piece of software they add
on which would crank this to work out
exactly right so this is what price
point we should yeah i kinda yep yeah
and so I was like well let me just we
had the data so I kind of grabbed put
data dropped in an Excel and what I did
was I was trying to I was trying to work
out how did how to make this this make
it stick to this formula it's called
linear regression basically you have
data points scattered and trying to find
a line that fits it the best way and
it's what you're doing physics and it's
a way you sort of you know there's a lot
of experimental stuff it's like what is
the formula you trying to get a model
that fits the tomato yeah it's a model
but the model is super precise to like
infant infinitely many decimal points
the data is messy it's like it's all
over the place it's all there there's
all these other factors [ __ ] trying to
find something so i was trying to find
something in this data anyway there was
no equation for linear the the
regression required the fitting there
was it wasn't in Excel because I
understand maths I knew the equation was
as one on ax plus B it was a one on a
linear formula so I knew if I took half
of the data and inverted that I could
find a straight line that fitted and
then I could invert that and I'd come
back and I basically worked out a way
using the formulas in Excel how to make
this work and what I did this took me in
afternoon and I presented it and what
that what that meant to the managers was
that this guy is spent an afternoon
save us quarter of a million dollars hmm
because it's not just knowing not using
the computers it's the fact that i can
think you had a you solve that problem
solves it alone yeah yeah i saw i solved
a problem because i knew how to i knew
how to kind of operate the machinery and
it's some and what's crazy is like
reading about reading about the moon
shot so when they went to the moon and
the computers they use their i mean back
in the 60s oh man the computers they use
were just so rudimentary i mean you know
a clock radio would have more computing
power now then the weren't were they
used for the moon but they were so smart
they they they worked those numbers and
were able to think of cleverly how to
use things and and and and that was like
because I was so much into space um the
Voyager spacecraft that left was fired
in 1977 or something Voyager to flu and
passed all the major planets in the
other says it's just alert that's right
so it's like Jupiter Saturn Uranus
Neptune and when it passed through his
saturn chunk of rock hit it and so
something stopped working hmm so its
actual arm it had this maneuver alarm
with all his senses and stopped working
so it was it was disabled hmm by the
time it reached Neptune in 89 because
people knew had a program better it was
a smarter spacecraft in 1989 and it was
in 1977 that's incredible so it could do
more in 1989 than it could do when it
was launched and was fully functional it
was the same piece of hardware course no
one's gone hours lettings didn't send
anyone out there to go can fix it like
they've they've used intelligence to
update that's right the way it actually
functions that's right and and that's
and that's what i mean i don't know if
this is a motivation but it's a reality
is that
is that if you want to have a great job
you've got to be able to think
mathematically you have to be because
you know the the the way that not yet
for example and they were first kind of
working out when I rained the mobile
world when they had the small mobile
phones or it had sore thumbs on you know
the the sending around data is certain
that was a super hard problem to solve
and the way they solved it was sending
packets like it's crazy the maths is
crazy they had to do but they had to
crack these problems you crack these
problems the rewards are enormous and
facebook now facebook we use was using
the type of maths which at one point no
one thought was applicable anything so
networks and and graph theory in graph
theory air so ramsey ramsay Theory
actually did there was a number file
thing i did about that talking about how
much you can infer from clicks and
people knowing each other or not knowing
each other but they are using that
they're crunching a lot of numbers on
mats and they're using it in this really
some say scary way but they're using all
this knowledge and they're getting stuff
out of it so gain insights when you know
how to work the done yeah yeah so
there's there's all this great stuff and
you know the algorithms they use of what
you're seeing and you know it's like why
am I seeing this and we know they're
making the making decisions based on how
you're interacting all that stuff is is
mathematical and so if you really want
to differentiate yourself out there
we're in a very unique position in
Australia where we have the opportunity
and the space and thankfully the you
know a peaceful society for the most
part
you can actually spend time getting this
working hmm and then you can go off
around the world it's bestest thing is
they don't take don't take all their
intelligence about Riley the brain drain
yeah right you know but like but you can
go over you can go over season you can
do amazing stuff